Tampa Florida is with us Victoria is on
the line high Victorian how are you get
Harry Oh better than I deserve what's up
I had a quick question I just start
listen to your program a few weeks and
no it's been saving up I do have my
first know Jordi had myself dollars
saved up and that's for my emergency
fund and I'm working on paying off my
debt my question is that I'm curling the
real estate industry and I do eventually
want to start investing in real estate
and other you know forms and in this
thing I was sure what the best course of
action should be I'm trying to see
excuse me pay off all my debt but I
wanted to find out is it possible for me
to try to find a way to maybe increase
my income doing something else still
saying where I'm at but you know doing
something dition to what I'm doing
currently what do you do you're in the
real estate industry what do you do I
work on the escrow closing side of real
estate so I'm the person you feel yeah
so it's no there's no commissions or
anything like that but I wasn't sure if
I should just just work on just saving
and not put any of that money into
investing or or if I could maybe
possibly try to do both at the same time
I wouldn't do any investing in real
estate while you're getting our debt you
need to clean up your debt and get a
fully funded emergency fund and that
kind of thing before we even start
talking about those other kinds of
things but I think overall what you're
looking at is you're looking at your
career is a you're on a salary you're on
a fixed income or basically a fixed
income and what can I do to dramatically
increase that the only options are one
of two generally speaking one is some
kind of entrepreneurial thing where you
have an idea and you start a business a
good way to do that start it on the side
and then let it grow let it grow to
enough that it explodes and becomes your
full-time gig and then the other
possibility of course is something where
you're on more of a commission income
more of a sales situation typically and
and obviously then in most of those
situations it's up to you to increase
your income by making more sales in your
case you don't get paid you know if you
close one house a day
or do the escrow on 10 houses a day you
get paid the same that day
carton yeah and so your production does
not affect your income every day on a
daily basis or a monthly basis now
long-term if you don't produce they're
gonna let you go and if you do produce
they're gonna keep you around and give
you a raise but but overall you're not
you know you don't have the ability to
double your income right and sorry you
know you may want to just kind of look
at your career track and go what is this
an entrepreneurial itch that I have that
needs to be scratched or is it something
else and you know or am I do I want to
own a title company someday an escrow
company do I want to move in that
direction some way because you know that
business so I you know I don't know but
but yeah I think I think you kind of got
to study that and think your way through
you know what does Victoria want to be
doing with her life that causes her to
smile which would include making a lot
of money five years from now and ten
years from now and 20 years from now and
you have to do that intentionally good
question thanks for calling you know I
heard Earl Nightingale who was if you
don't know who he is he was one of the
fathers of motivational speaking back in
the 60s and I heard him say one time
sometimes people spend more time picking
out a suit of clothes than they do their
job how does a young man young woman
coming out of school make a decision on
where they're going to work well George
they're hiring over there at the factory
once you come over and sign up all right
38 years later he wakes up he's still at
the factory he literally would spend
more time picking out a pair of shoes
and you know it's nothing wrong with
that that's not the end of the world but
I mean you're spending your life on this
you're spending the essence of who you
are on this whatever this is and so you
ought to do it freakin on purpose hello
yeah you ought to be intentional about
it and that's that's all Victoria's
doing she's very wise to have these you
know I have these questions because you
you know you don't want to just coast
and you do want to spend you know I
heard that so-and-so is a good place to
work so what that's one
part of the equation but what are you
supposed to do that gives you joy that
gives you delight because I got to tell
you there's very few times you're going
to be giving other people delight your
employer and your customers when you're
not delighted when you say I hate my job
let me just help you with that most
people hate working with you and that
would include the customers because you
come in looking like you were weaned on
a pickle your little face is turned
inside out and it's off on ugly your
spirit sucks I hope you know I don't
think you can everybody what you need
nothing from you you know don't be that
guy you know as victorious very wise to
think about that so it's a good
challenge for us to all to stop and say
hey we need to be intentional we need to
do things on purpose especially when it
comes to our work choices you know you
gonna spend your life with your spouse
you spend some time dating them you
figure it out you think about it you
choose carefully you spend your life
that's your job and your career choice
maybe you ought to spend some time
thinking about it and choose carefully
that's very wise Victoria very wise this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you